okay let's go back to the phones at six
one seven eight three zero
forty seven fifty a lot of folks
interested in chatting
let's go to our caller from the 636 area
code call her from 636 what's your name
where are you calling from
hello david this is luke hey luke
so i have a pretty simple question um
so you see the video of george floyd
and uh that's really kind of seems to be
what set off these uh current black
lives matter protests that we're having
and i just wonder like why is it that
this is the thing that finally set it
all off do you think it was just
four years of trump and tension building
up because we've known for a long time
that the black community has been
experiencing
uh all these injustices and nothing's
really set it off yet to this extent
anyway that's nice it's a combination of
things i think you had
number one uh a population
that is as unemployed as it has been for
a long time because of the virus so you
had a lot of people
already sort of aching to get involved
in something that
felt good they weren't most people
weren't going to do the anti-mask
protest because that's idiotic most
people understand what's going on with
the virus
so you had an incident that was on video
it was so egregious that even many
people
on the right said hey this was wrong
there's like i can agree
even people on the right and you know
i'm gonna let you go because there's
some there's some kind of noise there
i'll i'll answer offline
um so you had people see the video of
what happened with george floyd
you had overwhelming agreement that it
was an injustice
you did not initially see the officers
arrested
people are more home than they've been
for a long time and so it was sort of
like the perfect storm
then the president reacted in the worst
possible way
by saying oh protests against police
brutality
i encourage the governors to dominate
the protesters and i'm sending in the
military
and that exploded things even more so it
was a perfect storm of sorts would be my
perspective